notre pays qui supportent militairement
et financièrement ce système a une
responsabilité ces mots résonnent
tragiquement aujourd'hui c'était plus
d'un an avant le génocide rwandais en
1993 alors que le pays est en pleine
guerre civile
jean carbonare membres de la fédération
des droits de l'homme pointé la
responsabilité de la france de retour
d'une mission sur place
il ne peut retenir son émotion on a
trouvé des femmes qui sont terrés au
fond de la forêt depuis des semaines
avec leurs enfants
on peut faire quelque chose on il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose pour elle ce
génocide des tutsi plusieurs
observateurs l'avait vu venir
tout commence en octobre 1990 la guerre
civile éclate au rwanda deux populations
s'affrontent d'un côté les hutus
majoritaire dans le pays
de l'autre les tutsis discriminer depuis
des décennies le 1er octobre des membres
du fpr en majorité des tutsis exilés
l'once une offensive armée au nord du
rwanda avant de parvenir jusqu'à la
capitale kigali
la nuit dernière des rebelles sont
arrivés jusqu'au centre ville
armés de fusils et de mitraillettes ils
ont ouvert le feu sur des soldats
rwandais qui ont riposté à la
mitrailleuse lourde et où tout réplique
très violemment pendant des années ils
vont traquer chasser et massacré les
tutsis dans tout le pays
on m'a attrapée
on m'a frappé on m'a fouillée et au mas
on m'a menacé 1992 des milices
génocidaires sont créés les interhamwe
composé d' extrémistes hutus partout des
charniers sont découverts des cadavres
déterrés des faits rapportés par les
médias comme ici en janvier 93 plus à
l'est dans le village de kiné guy on
creuse dans la propriété même du maire
les ossements remontent à la surface
et monsieur le maire harbour une
attitude faussement incrédule ça s'est
passé chez lui il ne sait rien le
soupçonne rien
cette haine des tutsi un média
l'encouragent jour et nuit sept jours
sur sept
la radio des mille collines sur les
ondes elles incitent publiquement au
meurtre divulguer des noms de personnes
à abattre des primes sont offertes en
échange de cadavres nous voulons pas en
quatre ans après le début de la guerre
civile un événement va faire basculer le
pays
le 6 avril le président rwandais juvénal
habyarimana est assassiné le génocide va
commencer dès le lendemain pendant trois
mois environ 800 mille rwandais
essentiellement des tutsi sont tuées
selon l'onu
[Musique]